good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy wednesday it
is hump day which is extremely
appropriate given the fact that it's
also a brazen's drastic rising browsing
browsing shots and days bryce is here
stress is here
jackie's here jackson claude are here
claude is here there's a lot going on
double the strike double the fun double
the toast we have an amazing episode
today and i don't just say that lightly
you know you don't not only is it it
sounds like me i know i know but i never
say it so i think that when i say it it
has gravitas and when i say it it's
meaningless just because you know it's
like the boy who cried amazing episode
but let's be real every episode is
amazing took the words right out of my
mouth it's true but i can guarantee
or your money back
but today's episode you're gonna like
what you hear you're gonna guarantee it
here's why okay it's hump day which
always just gives an amazing energy puts
a little um a little
pump
in our day
two we had a very long weekend so we are
refreshed we are excited and we have a
lot to say to each other because not
only were there not two episodes monday
and tuesday but they happen to be like
earth-shattering breaking news
life-changing days which leads me to
point number three great stories five
out of five are ten out of ten and
dear toasters which is always a good
time helping the youth yes so between
those four bullet points that we have
just laid out to you i think we have
made the case for why this will be a
fantastic episode and the verdict is
amazing show
amazing sha
guilty ooh
fanny brass and stress
you guys we have so much to talk about
before we get into the stories let's
talk about the real stories here me and
you
[Laughter]
before we talk about the stars let's
talk about the true stars and it's been
so long we celebrated your birthday oh
my god you no longer had the birthday
blues you had a birthday blowout i had a
need to tell everyone what we did and
how you feel so i spoke like for the
week leading up to my birthday that i
hate my birthday i'm not doing anything
for my birthday which you do every
single year and then we're all obligated
to you know put on a tight dress and go
to the club please you wore a collared
shirt no that's why this year was
different from all other years it's true
so you know the day before my birthday
or the day before the saturday night my
birthday was sunday so i was like on
friday night i'm like i have to do
something and there actually were like a
decent amount of my friends in in the
city not everyone but a good amount
and i wanted to be not like other girls
because i'm
not
um
and instead of throwing like a party
like whatever i decided to do something
a little different you know
channel my inner seneca lake days at
camp seneca lake they would always
spring on us for evening activity a
mystery bus ride we usually went to like
juggies for food or
it was pretty much always dougie's which
was good by the way not complaining not
complaining literally but every time
you're like i wonder where we're going
you're going to juggies [ __ ] shut up
um and if you haven't eaten doggies like
you haven't lived it's like kosher like
fast food it's so good yeah whatever so
i was like let me do a mystery bus ride
because honestly i love a party bus and
sometimes the party bus is more fun than
the location of the party it's not about
the destination it's about the journey
right so i'm like all right i'm gonna
get a party bus everyone who's in town
just come and then i'll like find a
location for everyone um and so i went
through a lot of different ideas i
thought about maybe doing an escape room
which because i've never done one but
escape rooms or at least the ones i
found in the city like don't have like a
bar so like after you do the escape room
like you just go home like i mean it's
about your new knowledge
with all your escapism so i was like
okay not that i was trying to think of
like fun different maybe topgolf once
again here we are advocating for a top
golf in the city the for the closest one
is an hour and a half away in edison new
jersey which i don't want to make people
be on a bus for an hour and a half a
mystery bus ride is fun but not that fun
no and like you go extra slow in a bus
so google maps is like yeah if you're in
a sedan but they're not giving me the
party bus eta it's probably more like
two hours you have to drive slower you
can't go on certain roads you know yeah
that was like when we took a big party
bus to foxwoods and on the way home we
took a path that wouldn't allow our
truck and we were driving around
connecticut trying to find our way out
we took the path of most resistance we
really did so i was like i want to keep
it in the city i don't want to
inconvenience anyone and i was just
doing my research and this is not even
sponsored i actually paid a lot of money
a little too much i was my only
complaint about the venue extremely
expensive
um
to go to bolero and chelsea piers which
is bulmer rebranded it is obviously a
bowling alley but it's like a full bar
full arcade laser tag and i was just
like let's embrace because you know as i
was saying on the toast last week we're
all a child at heart you know yes and if
you're saying that and i think that was
like the inspiration for my party so i
didn't tell anyone we were going we all
met at my house got on the bus it was
like alcohol spritz music and everyone
was trying to guess it's funny how
literally everyone thought i was taking
them to atlantic city which is a good
idea but like do you think i would
really make you sit on this bus for four
hours like that's the kind of friend you
think i have and it's like taking your
friends on like a mystery trip to
a whole other state and city like that
it's like do you think you're kim
kardashian thank you by the way going to
chelsea piers thank you like i'm a
podcaster okay like please times are
tough
um and like do they think they were
coming back i would have told them to
pack out an overnight bag like they i
think they might have thought like you
had clothes for them there like no
jackie literally every single person
thought we were like and fully confirmed
they weren't even like we already know
i'm like you know that's so funny and
i'm like okay if we were going to
atlantic city i would have made us leave
at like six o'clock not 10 p.m like it
was people are so dumb okay
so then jackie actually had a great idea
because i wanted to make you know the
mystery bus fight more of an adventure
and i wanted people to start guessing
where we were going
so you had the great idea to play a song
um like different songs to
give clues right so the first song i
played was bowling for soup 1985 which
just got the [ __ ] crowd lit the [ __ ]
up it slapped every single person on the
bus who everyone's so different
different ages
everyone knew every single lyric i had
no idea i knew every single lyric but i
did and then when i finished it everyone
was like we're going bowling i'm like
kind of
so then i played um like the number one
song by major laser which i don't even
know what lean on yeah i don't know how
does it go we all need someone to lean
on
so then everyone was loving that song
and then they were like a major laser
i'm like yes someone said laser tag i'm
like yes
then right before we pulled up i just
typed in arcade fire and played the top
song and i didn't know it but kristen's
husband pete was like we're going to an
arcade i was like yes pete we've got
bowling we've got arcade we've got laser
track i've got socks for everyone get
off the bus it's party time
we went we had so much fun because like
if you're so many people at the bowling
place they give you like a little
package where it's open bar which just
makes everything more fun so we had
bowling alleys people were in the arcade
we did a big game of laser tag where
like i actually almost went into cardiac
arrest it's like not nearly as laborious
it was way more labor intensive than i
remember i could have told you i sat out
the laser tag because i just knew plus
that vest you have to put on your chest
like
yeah and i would have gotten a clog duct
it's way too heavy a hundred percent so
for that reason
so we did that for a couple hours and
then we went to the club it was like the
perfect combo of like good family
friendly fun partying people are saying
ben's friend matt said that it was the
best birthday party he's been to in 10
years in the decade that's what he said
what was the party 10 years ago i don't
know but like i must murder the person
so that might actually that would only
make their party even better like it was
their last grade
[Laughter]
right so maybe they were murdered
it was so fun and like i have been bold
in so long and that's how you know that
the world is healing and that covet is
over if if i am bowling and sticking my
fingers into those holes it's really
disgusting it was so disgusting but i
sanitized after every trip
down the alley yeah and you were very
good i was very good everyone's always
so surprised when i'm just so
competent at everything and not to like
be that person but it's
it's we talk about this all the time
like i am not
great at anything but i am good at
everything what would you rather be i
would say you're great at being bryce's
mom you're great at being harold's mom
you know what i mean you're an amazing
podcaster you're actually an excellent
excellent dancer like above average
that's true so don't put yourself down
girl no but i can do a little bit of
everything but i don't like
excel at one particular skill like like
how you sing right and yeah and act and
comedy yeah yeah but it's nice because
then like whenever we're doing something
i i can hold my own and if we had gone
to an escape room even though it would
kill me to play a game like i would have
cracked it of course like you would
literally need to do escape rooms
professionally you would be so good at
it you're so smart because i just want
to get out of there so like i'll just
figure it out i'm motivated i'm very
motivated also the funniest thing
happened while we were bowling because
there was a lot of food which was
delicious and gorgeous and in between
like every time i was bowling obviously
i would sanitize or wash my hands before
i picked up food because it was really
like finger food from the common space
right which is like there's nothing
grosser than bowling and bowling plus
eating is like it's wrong it's you
shouldn't do it and i heard ben say he's
like don't use your bowling hand he was
yelling at his friend victor he's like
don't use your bowling hand for the food
i'm like thank you ben please no one use
your bowling hand for the food it's
gross he goes
not gross grease you'll get grease in
the ball and you won't be able to bowl
as well oh because i was going to say if
ben is warning us on hygiene like we are
in trouble he was not he was warning
because he was worried how he was going
to affect your game if you had grease on
your fingers
well at least we have the common goal
the same right well also um just major
shout out like the food was literally so
good i people are still talking about
the honey mustard sauce like people are
like quaking to get the recipe yeah no
the cheese flatbread was really good
when it was hot this is what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah um so it was great i feel
like i i did my birthday really well and
then sunday was your actual birthday and
we had great family time which is just
like my kind of birthday meeting around
cake eating beauty and the beast
rolled
i pretty much spent my whole birthday
with rolled because i was with him all
day saturday and sunday and honestly i
think that's why i'm feeling so like at
peace with my birthday you know what you
were doing this weekend rolling
rolling
rolling on the rim no actually i was
kind of rolled in in the deep
actually
and this is actually a good segue i was
on the road again i just can't wait to
get on the road again and speaking of
i am going on the road again yes you are
please tell us you guys i'm so happy
that i can announce to you that
claudia's n log tour continues because i
saw the final show and then i saw it and
i was like
more people need to see this uh 100
so honestly when i first announced like
a new tour i was like so insecure coming
off of dirty jeans i felt like jt dj i
didn't think we could get better than
djt and i really felt like it was a
fluke like i put all my funny stories
everything into one and like it was just
going to live in information that's how
everyone feels about everything authors
in their first book you know the first
yeah with the first so then like when my
team was like let's put together another
tour i'm like yeah yeah yeah and i
really oh my god oh my god she was so
for clamps
said it i was trying to grab my lipstick
she was for clamped i was um i was
really like just being conservative i'm
like let's do smaller venues less shows
like i'm just not confident in my
abilities and then after like the first
10 or 15 shows i'm like oh my god i'm
literally born to do this i'm the
funniest person alive like the fact that
other comedians even bother getting up
in the morning is hilarious um and then
towards the end i was like we need to do
more
so now i feel like confident so if
you're
i'll
sorry
so it's the same show so if you've
already seen it you're more than welcome
to come again but it's not new material
i'm gonna finish out this year with this
material because i really feel like more
people should see it i agreed and then i
need to see it again so it's steered
into my memory so this week there will
be three shows announced that are just
local shows it's red bank new jersey new
haven connecticut and west hampton
because i'm like literally see that
again i wasn't paying attention red bank
new jersey great new haven connecticut
awesome west hampton new york
the hamptons no like literally am i
who's famous in the hamptons john bon
jovi
cherry springer am i
[Music]
hm
anything of a good like people like live
out there celebrities are always like
gwyneth is always you know who's been
spotted in the hamptons recently amber
heard dining at la bill bouquet in sag
harbor and shopping at t.j.maxx in the
hamptons oh really i think edward
hampton commons where you got your
sneakers oh my god so zach went to
bridgehampton commons tj maxx for me and
i needed sneakers because i forgot to
pack them because i forgot to pack
everything because i have a baby and he
was fully packed and had outfits for
days for months he could have stayed um
and he came back with all this stuff for
me and like it was so premium i'm like
so jealous of your sneakers every time
you wear them i love them they're adidas
sneakers and i they're so comfortable no
tjx is everything obviously amber her
nose hat so those are the three shows
announcing this week and then west
hampton just in case i wanted to make a
weekend in the hampton i want to say
august 12th oh it's june hampton's in
the summer of course wow it's gonna be
lit and it's a friday night so like we
can go out afterwards it's gonna be so
fun and then the rest of the shows i
just want to get those local shows out
no offense to red bank in new haven
those are going to be premium as well as
well yes and then all the places i
didn't go you know like
charlotte my my favorite city in the
world charlotte um i want to name some
others but i honestly don't want to say
the incorrect one and i can't remember
which ones we decided to go with and
which ones we didn't okay but just on
behalf of a certain um
geographical location could i ask if
there will be a
nashville show oh um yes there will be
okay good that was that was the impetus
behind the whole second tour like the
nashville toasters basically um came to
my house and
slaughtered my throat and like killed my
family um so then i was like alright
well i have to add nashville so let's
add a bunch more great i'm so happy for
the national toasters i never stopped
fighting for you she didn't ever not
once narry not once yeah i was like you
can go back on the road as long as
you're going to nashville so all those
shows will be announced coming soon but
this week there are some local shows and
i'm really excited even though like now
like the pit starts again yes but you
live for the pit you know and you live
for the drama um i resent that and i
don't no but you do it's just like how
even with msg like you were so nervous
so nervous you were pooping i can't wait
till i'm pooping and i don't have a show
ahead of me and then you were deeply
depressed when it was over that's
actually so [ __ ] true so you like it
and that's part of being the performer i
love it that's why you are born to
perform only i only get like a really
big pit when i haven't performed in a
while because people are always like do
you get nervous to be in front of the
amount of people the scale of what i'm
doing never like gets me it's always
will i remember what joe comes next like
always the structure of the show even
though i literally wrote it it's
embedded in me i i'm always nervous i'm
gonna like literally just blank
and i have blanked before but you would
never know because i'm such a consummate
professional well that's because you're
just funny so even if you didn't
remember you know the thing you were
supposed to say you say anything and
it's funny right right but i just like
i'm really hard on myself about like
remembering everything to go in order
yeah and that's really hard for you
considering my memory i should have
literally gone into any other business
you know
yeah so and log is coming back and
that's kind of like the breaking news of
the day you know like kind of the week i
feel like that's really what everyone's
talking about i agree now they will be
now that you told them 100
great well i feel like we've covered
everything
from the long weekend yeah oh i read
such a cute book last night i actually
read like like in one night yeah i
probably stayed up till three finishing
it like i'm so good on a really big
reading kick and i'm so proud of you and
i i
i'm
actually shocked that it's lasted this
long usually you go like a week you read
a lot you read enough bad books that you
go back to tv and then i don't read for
six months right but you're still on
your reading kicks
and i actually finished my book and
started a new one so i have some updates
this is like a classic book everyone's
been telling me to read and like i
started it and it was so dumb i'm like
this is embarrassing i got three percent
and i was like i can't and then last
night i just could not find something to
read so i just was like let me pick it
back up because i hate having unfinished
books what's it called the love
hypothesis oh my god that's all over
goodreads and it's one of those books
that i just won't read for the sake of
it jackie it was so cute like
at midnight ben was like can we please
go to bed i'm like yeah i couldn't go to
bed i'm like i i was like maybe 75 but i
still had an hour and a half left and i
was like
tossing and turning let me just finish
his [ __ ] book and i literally stayed
up till three
it was so cute it was a the ending
bothered me a little like she was just
like dragging it out a little bit and
like everyone in the book was scientists
so like there was like so many science
like
metaphors and like it was like a like a
little too much science but it was
really cute like it was adorable i loved
it so it's worth all the hype and every
list that it's on and why goodreads is
always pushing it and it's like always
everywhere yeah okay good i'm glad i'm
glad that quality books are the ones
that are being pushed forward like that
not books like no offense the people you
meet on vacation agreed i hated that
book and now i won't read um beach read
or her new one book lovers because it
just wasn't for me there was so much
hype and i finished it and it was like
cute whatever i'm like but this is the
book everyone's waiting for the whole
time i know oh my god it was like kind
of gross yeah um what did you read so i
finished tom sagura's book he's a
comedian and a podcaster and a parent so
it was a perfect thing and he's i think
they spoke about this he's married to
christina p we did so i'm like now such
a big fan of theirs no we just keep
talking about them until tom reaches out
because christina already has and it's
funny because like we podcast sort of in
a vacuum like and actually we're friends
with a lot of the other like female
podcasters but we don't really know any
of the other comedy podcasters yeah
because we are a pop culture comedy
podcast and when it comes to like our
social life we know the other pop
culture podcast yeah we really don't
know the other like comedian podcasters
right that are on the charts alongside
us and we've never had their mcdonald's
yeah but when i choose pop culture yeah
when i
picked up his book and it's like he has
two podcasts one your mom's house which
then i looked at the cover art i always
see it and the other one two bears one
cave that's always on the choice so it's
so nice to like now know the people and
appreciate their work you're knowing
your neighbors we sit alongside them so
i and then the other people are like
conan and those guys from the office
yeah um tim dillon tim dillon who i love
yeah it's actually my favorite i am so
to be alongside him it's it's simply an
honor it's just an honor to see our
photo side by side sometimes no when i
think about like the male comedy
podcasters like you'll send me clips of
like things you find funny or i'll just
see them on tik tok or instagram reels
and they're always saying like crazy
outrageous things and like of course i
find it so funny but i also find it
shocking that like they say the most
crazy things like completely unaffected
and like we are like i'm like kept up at
night by like one thing i said six
months ago that like i i didn't mean and
it was like did people think i take it
the wrong way is buzzfeed gonna write an
article about it like and these other
like mostly male podcasters are just off
saying the most [ __ ] insane like
controversial [ __ ] i'm like i wonder if
they like are kept up at night no i i
think we just have really different
audiences i think so too you know yeah
so
it was a really good book five stars
book of short stories if you're into
comedy
recommend highly i actually recommend it
to you too and then i started two nights
ago the hotel nantucket by ellen
hildebrand it's her new book and i'm six
percent in and she she hooked me yeah
she's that one's on my list the writing
is just like fast people like it in the
first chapter i really like ellen
hildebrand but like homegirl could cut a
few pages if it wouldn't kill her it
wouldn't kill her at all
yeah i guess but she you know she does
what she does and
it's working for her yeah obviously like
she's like who the [ __ ] is this shut up
girl you wrote one book and it was
literally five pages long oh um prime
day is over but i hope you guys were
able to get a copy of my book on prime
day would you get a prime day i got
the [ __ ] did i get i finally all day i
was looking for things and this happens
to me every prime day where i'm like i
need stuff so i invent stuff that i need
and and then i put in my card and i
usually don't get anything so i'm like i
don't need this crap why would i buy it
then i did
buy like two things yesterday dumb
things nothing primy even by the time i
clicked to buy the deal was over right
right right because there's like a
little countdown but i had a really good
idea for prime day that i shared with
you you did
because prime day like the lead up it's
overwhelming and then people have things
that they think they want to get and
then i think a lot of people like quake
under the pressure it's so much pressure
and don't end up really fulfilling their
prime day dreams so here's what i
propose to amazon if anyone's listening
prime day is too much pressure
everyone's shopping at the same time and
like we're all for clamped
and i think that every amazon prime user
should have their own individual prime
day whenever they
choose maybe
one day per year they say jeff
put me in coach i'm ready to prime i
know what i need right now in a place
where i need things and i want to use
all my prime day savings today yeah
well then also it creates like this so i
got a new kindle i took a lot of
recommendations and i ended up getting
the oasis did i wind up getting a new
kindle i meant to right well here's my
dilemma i have the kindle paperwhite i
love it so much but it's crapping out i
had to restart it the other night
because it looked like you know a tv
yeah static machine i restarted it and
now it works but i do have an a kindle
oasis that was meant to be zach's that
he didn't use so now it's mine and i
could always
move to that so i do have a bathroom i
don't need it
i don't need to get a new one
but i kind of want a new paper white
because i did read two books on the
oasis and it wasn't enough to hook me
yeah so i got it and i also got a new
knife set because like i was literally
cutting an apple the other day like a
chain like a saw like it was a piece of
wood it was like back forth back it was
like like a piece of wood
look like piece of wood honestly shadows
of sunset getting canceled is a disgrace
to humanity it's a disgrace to the
culture and it's to disgrace to women
who are actually beautiful and women who
look like pieces of wood you look like
there's so many like literally when i'm
with my friends from high school all we
do is quote jazza sunset it's so funny
you look like piece of wood your cans
look sick when mj got to the altar her
husband looked at her and was like you
can't look sick i know you know what
other cans look stick spritz society
yeah by the way i just want to say i was
drinking peach society at your birthday
and i pull more turn this off if you're
listening i snuck a few cans in for
myself because it was just my drink of
choice and i didn't want to have a
watered-down vodka soda that's not gonna
happen like i never get out i want a
[ __ ] spray and i put it in my purse
and everybody was jealous of me it was
so delicious i haven't had a night out
on peach yet i've like had one tasted
them we had the uh influencer event but
like to party on peach
no this is like the third time i've been
out with spritz like in the party bus
when we did um when we were in the
hamptons we went to bounce they
bounce was carrying spritz like we had
it at the club it's just a perfect drink
like for a club it's a great chaser for
a shot of tequila it's a great thing to
drink when you don't want to like keep
drinking hard alcohol yeah and it's a
great when you're like the granny in the
group but you want to drink it's just
like not aggressively right oh my god it
was a delight i had such a great evening
i didn't have a hangover but i was like
with everyone partying and it was so
to to to taste it taste it
toast also peach is now in total wine oh
yes we're rolling out in stores now so
check your local total wine but if you
don't have a local total wine go to
spritzsociety.com slash toast um also
this is so random i just felt like a
piece of trivia that i wanted to share a
piece of wood
do you know what rsvp stands for
no and have you ever thought about what
it stands for no
respond
soon
very pleased literally i thought the
same thing
no a responder civil play
oh my god
i didn't know our cb was french i know
and it's funny how rsvp has become a
verb so nobody even remembers that's an
acronym and like maybe we should be
thinking about what it stands for oh my
god responded
thank you for that fun fact you're
welcome now i feel like maybe it'll come
up in like jeopardy i didn't know that i
spoke french
precisely
the morning crostini yeah we should do a
fun fact of the day
since they changed
their camp no let's talk about the whole
thing let's talk about the things people
need us to talk about so diet snapple
which has been literally the greatest
beverage on the planet since earth's
genesis um since literal genesis
literally
has
gone through a change now the first
change is that if you go to your store
you will not find diet snapple it's
called diet snapple zero sugar no it's
not it's called snapple zero sugar sorry
snapple zero sugar because i guess the
word diet is like a slur now
um so
don't be confused because i did
instacart and these things arrived and
on instagram it said diet sample and
then when it arrived it said snapple i'm
like oh my god i would never drink not
that i care about like calories like
it's really too sugary i don't even know
what it tastes like because to me it's
like drinking acid like you just you
obviously drink diet sample what's
sociopath drinks regular snapple like
it's psychotic to me yeah
and i'm like oh my god i can't use this
and then i looked on the back and it was
like locale big flop five calories i'm
like wait snapple was diet sample was
zero calories is this the new diet
snapple they added five calories to be
like to appease like diet culture it's
always had that oh
we said zero uh
no it's always had like negligible
amount of calories right okay whatever
so i was just like oh my god i had to do
like the the research on my own to
realize that diet snapple doesn't exist
anymore it's snapple's aeroshock you had
to educate yourself i had to humble
myself and educate myself and i just
think it's really dumb
because like if something's perfect
don't change it i agree and by the way
we missed glass bottles they nothing was
tastier nothing like these they still
taste good yeah they do still taste good
it doesn't taste the same if you can't
go
right
get a little glass in your bottle no
yeah breaking the bottom i mean have you
ever dropped a full 12k 12 case of
snapple on your kitchen floor and it
shattered completely because i have oy
maybe that's why they stopped to doing
glass it's worth the risk it's worth the
risk but i will say it still tastes
pretty good and the new bottles have a
saying that has just taken over my life
which is local big flav locale big flav
and i think they mean flavor yeah flavor
or flav but flav is
flavor
so that's added a lot of joy to my
everyday every time i see it i chuckle i
just feel like this whole like diet
culture conversation has taken on like a
life of its own because like yes are
there parts of diet culture that are so
toxic yes but is having the word diet in
your like beverage title like gonna
have a negative impact on people like no
no and there are parts of everything
that are so toxic did you see those
accountants cheating
on their cpa exam i did like the ethics
part no less either engage or disengage
yeah some people like diet culture right
that's true some people like
diets have helped them right no for sure
it's just like it's
and i just don't think like the problem
with diet culture is going to be solved
with snapple changing their name at
least they kept big flop so true for
those of us who love flowers for the
flow of culture which is so toxic
flavor of love oh man don't get me
started i'll go into my tiffany pollard
monologue i prefer flavor of love but
that's just me me too because we're
women of taste obviously yeah and you
know what like maybe we should get into
the fast size story sure i just want to
say i didn't meet flavor flav
did you yeah
simon's wedding he wasn't even at the
wedding the wedding was at a hotel and
he just happened to be the bar and i
went to the bathroom he was standing
there with a clock and i'm like is that
flavor flavor did you say what time is
it summer time no i said what time is it
flavor time it's a vacation what time is
it flower time time of our lives
screen's out let the shot okay we could
go on but i think maybe you're right
right like there's so much to talk about
today i'm sure people are tuning in
because they wanna skip skip skips i
hope you didn't because everything that
we said needed to be said so important
no but actually
but actually you think i was joking i
don't think i don't take this seriously
you like rolled your eyes so it's hard
no that's my new personality you know
like
like quirky girly oh cute yeah i like
that i'm trying on new personalities for
size yeah i like the original recipe but
i'm sure you'll realize this at the end
of your journey
but you still have to go on it yeah to
realize who you really are is enough so
true
okay without further ado
where are you
he is sleeping soundly
so is brew
right next to his mommy that was good
ended there like on a high it is time
for the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
sports society sports society.com you
can use code toast we've got five
fabulous flavors of our sparkling
sparkling wine based it's because of
flowers
sparkling wine based cocktails uh we got
peach we got grapefruit we got lemon we
got pineapple we got blood orange
they're so delicious it's the drink of
the summer drink it in a can pour it
over ice you'll have the best time
alfresco dining love you
available in select locations in chicago
illinois
in california in massachusetts in
florida in texas we're at total wine
we're at bevmo so check the store
locator on the website if you want to go
into the store but you could also order
it online yeah super simple super simple
our first story the big story of the day
though there are many big stories i
would say curious what you consider the
biggest
real housewives of salt lake city star
jen shop pleads guilty in fraud case i
actually would consider the fanny story
the bigger story but maybe that's just
because i'm so invested in it perhaps i
just feel like this is it this is the
big news jen shaw pleaded guilty on
monday in her federal fraud case
according to court documents obtained by
page six shaw appeared in front of u.s
district judge sydney stein at 10 30 a.m
eastern time in manhattan federal court
for a surprise hearing during which she
changed her previous not guilty plea she
pled guilty to count one conspiracy to
commit wire fraud in connection with
telemarketing the u.s attorney agreed to
drop count to conspiracy to commit money
laundering
the judge made sure jen understood the
change and that she faces a maximum
penalty of 30 years in prison and five
years of supervised release but her plea
agreement called for only 11 to 14 years
behind bars and restitution of up to 9.5
million dollars prior to the one count
being dropped she had faced 50 years in
prison and was scheduled to go on trial
july 18th her sentencing is now
scheduled for november so we continue to
wait but she has pled guilty so i mean
when you plead guilty i think mostly
that's because you agree to a deal it
lessers your sentence
so um
i think it's pretty much certain now she
will be doing some time in prison it's
just a matter of how much yes time that
is um and if you plead guilty that means
there's no trial there's no
cross-examination like she just gets
sentenced and her sentence will be in
november yeah
so this is so unexpected and so crazy
not because i don't think she's guilty i
think there's literally no shadow of a
doubt in my mind that she is guilty but
because she's so like indignant and like
so um
almost like patronizing in her innocence
you know she's gonna fight for all the
people who've ever been wronged
so the fact that she admitted to herself
let alone her lawyers and the government
in the world that she's guilty that's
what's so shocking to me about this not
the fact that she's guilty i wouldn't be
surprised if she takes the
route of saying that she took a plea
deal
because she like couldn't win and that
she's still innocent but you know she
didn't have a choice the best choice and
made the best choices and i would not be
surprised if she maintains her innocence
socially right but in the court it just
was the best sense legally the best
decision legally though i agree with you
like i think she's guilty you know stu
was going to testify against like there
even if they went to trial likely she
would have been proven guilty but
somehow like admitting guilt
just you know she's just safe stubborn
she's so stubborn yeah the i mean the
odds were so stacked against her like
the case against her is so strong and
then her assistant slash partner slash
whatever he is turning on her and
agreeing to testify against her to save
his ass was like the final nail in the
coffin and even then
she didn't even blink or act like it
made a big deal because made a
difference because she was so innocent
it's it's really so crazy and i'm just
curious you know what her sentencing is
going to be yeah because
the plea deal likes calls for 11 to 14
years
so she's going to jail for a minimum of
11 years right or like a maximum of 14
years but still
it's gonna be even one year two years no
she will be in prison she will be in
prison and her crimes like i can't help
but compare them to teresa's her crimes
are way worse than theresa's because
theresa's were self-serving the only
person teresa was frauding was the
government and honestly we've all
thought about it once or twice you know
evading your taxes they weren't stealing
money from other people like jen was
taking not only was she stealing money
from innocent people a lot of them it
was particularly vulnerable communities
i can't imagine a judge feeling
sympathetic no to a person like that
right and i don't think her presence on
the show helped helps garner sympathy
because she doesn't seem apologetic you
know she's very indignant and
the life she was leading was so
outrageous then when you really think
about like these just poor like that's
something what someone's retirement fund
was your hands
right it makes it
so much worse and like even with teresa
like what you really could see a world
in which she's not the brightest bulb in
the shed like you could see a world in
which she was taken advantage of by her
husband and at the end of the day the
only people they were defrauding
were the government like i can't imagine
even if she had gone to trial i think it
would have been so much worse because
you don't know who a jerry is made up of
someone has a mom who was taken event
you know like
so i can't imagine a scenario in which a
judge doesn't impose like a maximum
sentence because not only are there
financial crimes and there's no like you
know nobody's dead
but it's so egregious like the targeting
of vulnerable communities the disabled
the elderly like it's so [ __ ] up it's
so [ __ ] up and so i think we've all
known you know she was likely guilty now
she's admitting guilt and my question is
what is bravo going to do here you have
a housewife who just said that she is
guilty of defrauding these vulnerable
elderly people
right does that cause they'll burn fire
are you going to film her tomorrow like
really
that's so [ __ ] to me
like i can't help but think of jenny wen
you know oh because they're the same
franchise like she got fired for her
political opinions and unsavory opinions
whereas jensha has just admitted that
she did these things these terrible
things
she's facing up to 14 years in prison
yet still they're gonna keep a camera on
her that's a really interesting
point i totally literally if you never
brought up jenny wednesday never again i
would never ever remember her because
she was so irrelevant and she should
have been fired for being irrelevant she
popped into my head this morning and i
was like hmm right
and now the gen thing has totally
eclipsed jenny so like nobody even
remembers jenny but that's a fair point
because
because jenny nguyen was just guilty of
not speaking correctly right whereas
like yeah gen cha but see like jenny wen
also wasn't adding literally any value
to the show i know so it's more nuanced
than that no but it's not when it comes
to like hiring and firing based on
crimes or perceived crimes it's not
about who's more entertaining otherwise
leanne would still be on the show that's
so true okay it's like so hard to argue
with you because like you're just like
right um but um nevertheless she
persisted let me just continue
no but i do agree with you but also at
the end of the day like bravo's bottom
line is ratings is entertainment and
that's
the this literally the story was
breaking news
so then why was leanne fired why was
stassi fired she's raiding she's
entertainment
yeah yeah no
well no because well bravo released a
statement with jenny when they released
a statement with saucy too that they
don't want to be associated with
those types of behaviors but they want
to be associated with this i think yes i
think they do actually that's that's
that i actually think they do okay like
for real like it it's salacious
and people don't look at it the way that
we look at it which is like
so unethical like so immoral what she
did they look at it as like this juicy
same with erica jane
yeah but i think people are able to
separate it because it was erica jane's
husband if this was sharif we would not
be having this conversation of course
right but also no i feel like and even
it was joe moore yes i don't even
theresa kind of is like irrelevant to
the conversation to me
but
i think that um people are more angry at
erica
than they are agenda than they are again
i agree
i think also people like want to see
erica fail go down and like they have a
reason now yeah a real reason yeah no i
think the conversation is particularly
nuanced and i i'm not sure what the
right answer is because this is what we
talk about all the time when it comes to
cancer culture like
there's a difference between you know
saying something bad and doing something
bad you know one of them is a crime and
the other is just like you know
unpopular
so
the energy that we reserve for people
who have old tweets or people whose
political opinions we don't like or
people who have posted things that we
don't agree with like
is so much bigger that energy we have to
cancel them is always like so much
bigger than the energy we have for
people who actually like do
horrendous things like illegal crimes
who hurt other people and that's where
cancer culture is flawed because if only
we had the type of energy
for um
let me think of a good example hold on
if only we have the type of energy that
we have for dave chappelle
that
let's channel that energy towards like a
chris brown you know who actually like
hurts women on the daily as opposed to
chappelle who considers himself an
artist and this is his art you know yeah
so it is complex
it is not to me really but i can see how
bravo might find itself confused and i
think bravo does has no problem
associating themselves with
crime honestly like i don't think they
find it nearly as abhorrent as like
jenny when or stop insane yeah that's
insane and i i mean i'll
i'm curious to see what they do they
probably won't do anything but
they're not going to do no [ __ ]
scribbles no [ __ ] scriptures
they're not going to do anything this is
the biggest story in the world and
they're at the center of it and they're
not going to you know put their morals
on blasts and be like oh no we couldn't
possibly like everyone's talking about
it it's a new franchise like for
networks like the bottom line is the
bottom line you know
but i think they've hurt their own
bottom line in the past in you know
service of their so-called
values yeah
perhaps perhaps
so that's that on that we'll see you in
november um
keeps getting pushed back like i just
i'm ready i need a story to rest i know
and the more it like gets pushed off it
sort of
desensitizes you to them to the
magnitude of the crimes 100 that's how i
feel 100 percent okay our competing big
story of the day leah michelle is taking
over for beanie feldstein in funny girl
on broadway the news came out
this week lea michelle is set to take
over beanie feldstein's starring role in
funny girl the broadway production
announced on monday the announcement
comes on the heels of beanie's shocking
instagram post late on sunday in which
she revealed she was leaving the show
earlier than expected leah will begin
performances on tuesday september 6th
alongside the cast and tony nominee tova
feldcha feldcha who will be taking over
for jane lynch didn't even know jane
lynch was a part of it oh you didn't
know that and so now another element of
this extremely layered story is that
leah michelle and jane lynch will not
even overlap at all even though they
were technically supposed to because of
jane's date do you think that jason
so okay let's start from the beginning
let's unpack the glee i read a
like an expose people are there's not
like a
nobody knows really the truth of what
happened but there was this big expose
that came out this morning and i did
read it and essentially what it was is
who put out the expose i don't want to
say their name because they're
discussing publication who should rot oh
okay cool
but nevertheless and if it's probably
filled with as many lies as the article
they wrote about us then i shouldn't
believe a word of it
so
basically
beanie was cast and almost immediately
the reviews were a bit small um
she is not a great singer and not only
is it broadway where you have to be a
great singer the role of fanny all the
songs of course don't rain in my parade
when you think of all the songs it's
like
it's really a role for one of the
greatest singers in the world not a girl
who can sing not a girl who can carry a
tune right and i feel like a lot of us
didn't even know that beanie could sing
and it's just one of those things like a
party trick you know like she has a nice
voice she probably performed in the
talent show
so
i it does feel like you know when when
funny girl was announced and they were
doing the casting you know the directors
went out of their way not
to cast lea michelle she's so the
obvious choice first of all she looks
like barbra streisand
she is notorious for being obsessed with
funny girl as leah michelle and also as
rachel berry
there's a generation of people who only
know what funny girl is because of
rachel barry and lee michelle so it's
like they really went out of their way
not to choose her and of course you know
business is business they didn't want to
be associated with someone who's having
like a big scandal at the time and i do
think that was a mistake because beanie
was a flop almost instantly and it's not
for lack of trying i think what i read
was that in the beginning she was a
delight to work with she knew the
reviews were negative but the you know
the production rallied around her it was
always really warm but where things got
really icky is like beanie got covered
and then she took a break a little bit
so the understudy julie benko played who
was
unbelievable because she's
a broadway
star
um and people started coming for julie
binko and i think a lot of people
thought when beanie left julie would
replace her because she was phenomenal
um and that's just always like your
understudies like should be good but not
better than you yeah um and so that's
where things started to get icky and
then in june early june there was an
article from gawker that lea michelle
was in talks with
the production to take over once beanie
left and when beanie read that she
became like incensed no one from the
production was allowed to talk to her
they only had to talk to her team she
was gonna leave early she was always
gonna leave early and then randomly
posted on instagram that she's leaving
even earlier nobody even knew that she
was posting that like something about
the lea michelle like set her off i'm
sure which is funny because when she got
the part she was doing press for the
monica lewinsky show and of course andy
being like the shady shady shaderstin
that he is asked her about it and she
was like oh my god i didn't even know
like this was a thing i don't know this
woman at all like she had no well she
said she had no clue about like the
drama so if you don't know her and you
don't know about like the rachel barry
of it all like why did the lea michelle
news bother you so much you knew you
were only doing it for six months
someone else was gonna have to do it
yeah
so
what the leah being the person after her
like allegedly
made her really mad and caused even more
strife within the production
but
they had an inside source from the
production team talking to this insider
article
and essentially the takeaway was like
beanie was horrendous the reviews were
abysmal and embarrassing but they
decided to stand behind her you know
stick with her and just ride it out but
then ticket sales were dropping so low
and like a production is
has investors it's a business you you
this is a business so they were making
you know plans for a big star to come in
and obviously it was it should have
always been liam michelle um
and that really pissed beanie off but
now i want to talk about the the
decision to go with leah because i for
one am absolutely over
the good news like leah michelle was
meant to play this role
say what you want about her lea michelle
is one of the most talented singers
actresses and broadway stars of our time
this role couldn't have been written
was written as much for her as it was
written for robert streisand like it's
literally i do have to say i love that
they're even though beanie didn't work
out i do love that both of the girls are
jewish because it's a jewish role and
like i just love that it's so authentic
um
and
leah is going to be marvelous and people
on broadway in like the theater space
are like en enraged they hate it
but talent is talent and nobody can sing
like lily michelle i'm sure she knows
the play by heart already she didn't
even have to go to her social to show up
on the first day and do everything she's
ever done she's going to be sensational
and you can either fight it or you can
lean in and try and get together aside
from beanie i guess the broadway people
but like we as a broadway girly no
people who think she's extremely
difficult to work with that was like her
big scandal right right her big scandal
on glee was that she was a nightmare and
we knew a little bit about it from nia
of era's book but it didn't really blow
up until a lot of the cast members
started to talk about it
um
and now it's just like a general
thing like
lea is a diva and she's mean and she's a
[ __ ] and she hides people's wigs
i do believe the uh
scandal has humbled her to no end i have
to imagine she will be an absolute
delight to work with this time around to
prove everyone wrong
um
and i'm like you know what it's gonna be
great and that's literally all that
matters like people come to a broadway
show for the singing the dancing the
acting and
nobody does it better than leah so you
can fight it but as kurt hummelwood said
she might be difficult but boy can she
sing
totally and you know what like
you're
there there's no one better i'm sorry
there's no one better people were
disappointed it wasn't julie benko the
understudy and you know what she
probably would have been great too but
they need a star beanie was supposed to
need to breathe life into this
production beanie was supposed to
reprise the role win the tony like be
that girl and she was not even close to
being that girl and they should have
done leah from the beginning and now
they're making it right and i'm sure
leah wanted to be the one to reprise the
role and be eligible for the tony and
have it be her thing but i'm sure she's
just [ __ ] grateful to be getting the
role now and she'll be great and if you
hate her then that's fine but you can't
deny that she's going to be excellent
and i would be shocked really shocked if
she behaves in the way that she did when
she was younger agreed after everything
that has happened no she's going to be
heavenly i imagine she has learned a lot
yeah and will be singing a different
tune literally though in the same
gorgeous pitch yeah i'm the and by the
way the production must be happy with
their choice literally the resale value
on their tickets is you want a shitty
seat it'll cost you 800 for opening
night of course you have to go i'm
trying everything that i can
if you watch glee like you know the if
you don't know what we're talking about
like you don't know why this is a big
deal but if you watch glee like you know
the cultural significance of rachel
barry of lea michelle of fanny bryce a
funny girl and like the fact that
literally art it well life is imitating
art right now
is just so crazy and the fact that
really it's like the fans and the outcry
that probably played a really big role
in this i do feel like oftentimes you
know we'll all say so and so should be
so and so and they're like shut up you
don't make decisions right but i do feel
like the fandom really helped sway the
decision here i would have been also
really happy if it was shoshana bean
another jewish queen who has one of the
best voices i've ever heard in my life
but um i'm happy with this decision
what's next you know what i did think
was interesting about i read in the
article um just like a conflict of
interest thing is that beanie and leah
michelle have the same talent agent so
like it's kind of like like a conflict
of interest that is weird yeah i'm sure
how can you represent your client to the
best of your abilities when you also
have the interests of another client who
you want to represent to the best of
their abilities damn it's weird yeah
this whole thing is like so dramatic and
i would love to really really everything
i've said here is purely like
speculation speculation i was going to
say skepticism there is so much smoke
here from not even that article that you
read i heard many similar things you
know there's doumois there's other
insiders saying this in that there's so
much smoke and by the way just looking
at it on its face it's like beanie was
cast there was a lot of you know
excitement for leah michelle and it kind
of eclipsed beanie's casting and
everyone said should have been her now
beanie stepping back she's announcing
too early and then they also announcing
michelle like
no there's
a fire
and you know for a role like this
reprising a world beanie would have
ordinarily in this situation done it for
a year and then a couple weeks ago it
was like there's only a few more months
to see
beanie and
then people put together that she was
only doing it for six months which is
just bizarre and now she she's ending
early she will have done it for four
months damn yeah and you know i do kind
of feel bad for beanie because it's like
so awkward and whatever i do believe she
tried her best and i don't think she's a
mean person or a bad person but it just
wasn't the right role for her and she
was miscast from the very beginning like
the one thing about fanny bryce is like
you have to be able to sing and all the
reviews were about her singing abilities
um and i do feel bad for her and it must
be like so awkward these remaining like
15 shows because they're still like 15
days until the end of the month you
should go see it because then you can
really compare and then you could come
here and tell us and don't go by the
reviews because honestly reviews like
are subjective
are so subjective we never agree with
the reviews that's true actually but you
know what i'm probably going online i'm
about to expose myself hard i've never
seen funny girl the movie
or the play i don't even i know like the
plot of it so the first time i see it
like i really want it to be leah
like that's why i feel like it would be
so special because my only real
association should watch the movie i
think you should see beanie and then you
should go see leah so that you can come
here and be an expert on the matter you
know what i think you're right that's a
fun activity for you hey mister uh and
by the way like ask me how upset i was
that i wasn't even considered after
shoshanna after shoshanna
hey mr owenstein
here i
am
i'll march my
band out i'll beat
my
drum
and if i'm thinned out your turn at bat
sir at least i didn't fake it hot sir i
guess i did make it get ready for me
love cause i'm a camera i've simply
gotta march my heart's a drum and no
but i don't know body is
gonna
rain on my
so it should have been me but um i'm
happy for liam michelle happy for her
and i'm happy for fanny brass and stress
and brass and strats and brass and
strats and brass and straps and brass
and straps and brass and straps and
strikes are also like devastated to have
been overlooked it should be fanny bryce
also strength and strength is the
understudy yeah but i was dying this
morning i had an epiphany when we were
talking about fannie bryce i was like
fanny brows and stress
but also he's dry sand
no
literally if we don't get tickets i'm
gonna die like yeah no you need tickets
you need to watch some of you have
homework to do yeah you do i do because
i want to know from an expert not from
the reviews not from the articles you
know what i would love to know
barbara's opinion who does she think
she's obviously so close to the role
like
who does she think should play it and
what are barbara's thoughts on lea
michelle because when liam michelle was
up and coming before the disgrace um she
really was like the next barbara you
know she didn't get her nose done
neither did barbara and she didn't get
it done because barbara didn't get it
done like
she was like
the modern barbra streisand like what
does barb barbs think yeah
they either have a very close
relationship or none at all yeah i could
see barbara like thinking leo was
annoying but you know what like
i think barbara's annoying totally i
just but annoying people don't like
annoying people no and like i'm sorry if
you want to be like a theater
girly like you are annoying like you
have to be singing all the time
uh people think i'm annoying because and
i don't even like have that good of a
voice like literally in order to be
rachel barry slash lee michelle like you
have to be the most annoying girl in the
world you can't be like a shy little
wall flower
like no it doesn't work yeah it comes
with the territory except for gabriella
montez but then she really broke out of
her shell and you know what hot take her
voice wasn't that good no it wasn't but
that was like the point yeah
okay let's move on
if we have exhausted if we must we have
exhausted and now it's time for the emmy
nominations which have been dropped and
here are the complete list of nominees
we are going to react and share our
votes
as we always do even though we don't
watch the enemies it's always nice to
hear what you know
people think is popular and good and i
watch way more tv than i do movies so
when it comes to like the big award
shows i think the one i probably have
the most invested in is the emmys
because i haven't seen a movie
well i saw top gun and it was so good
but other than that yeah best comedy
abbott elementary so good barry
unfamiliar
curb your enthusiasm so good hacks oh
the marvelous mrs maisel susan stunk
only murders in the building um that's
tough ted lasso oh [ __ ] what we do in
the shadows okay so i do think as much
as
i i don't think hacks is gonna win i
think it'll be between abbott elementary
and only murders in the building abbott
elementary is so good yeah you know
what's funny you would love it by the
way all the shows that i've seen here
they're amazing so that would just say
to me like then i should watch the other
shows in the categories i'd probably
like them too you should watch abbott
elementary it's all about the campers
and it has like such camper counselor
energy tell me i'm doing the best for
the kids so much on my content plate i
still haven't watched the summer i turn
pretty okay it's like literally 30
minute episodes it's good to watch like
mindlessly i haven't turned my tv on
aside from homework and southern charm
in weeks like one day just put it on
your plate next best best actress in a
comedy rachel brosnahan marvelous mrs
maisel she wasn't good i'm sorry i love
miss maisel this was not the season for
any of them to win okay and they had
their time in their time i feel like
it's past and maybe when their final
season they'll have another time or when
they do something noteworthy because
this last season was literally
treacherous yes quinta brunson abbott
elementary she's going to win kelly
cuoco the flight attendant no elle
fanning the great show stinks issa rae
insecure jean smart hacks
uh gene smart won last year
and honestly like if hax wants to keep
winning emmys they have to give us more
[ __ ] deborah vance and no more ava
um but i think abbott elementary's gonna
get this one
okay
best actor in a comedy
donald glover atlanta bill hader barry
nicholas holt the great
steve martin only murders in the
building martin short only murders in
the building jason siddakis ted lasso um
jason segas um
swept last year we were we hadn't
watched ted lasso yet but they won
everything will they win again
i'm fine with that i'm fine with that
too interesting that steve martin and
martin short are up against each other
that's like always awkward and cute yeah
and if i had to give it to one of them
it would be martin short his character
is so [ __ ] funny yeah he's he does it
the most yeah even though steve martin's
also great but his character's just not
as you don't look forward to hearing him
talk he's like kind of dreadful like
yeah but that's the point yeah yeah the
contrast yeah
supporting actress in a comedy
alex borstein the marvelous mrs maisel
hannah ein bender
it's funny that she's supporting
considering they're really 50 50 but um
i think like and especially this season
she was really 50 50. last season there
was more deborah than ava and now
they're equal and
it ain't right
janelle james abbott elementary kate
mckinnon snl sarah niles ted lasso
cheryl lee ralph
elementary juno temple ted lasso hannah
wattingham ted lasso hannah waddingham
was great yeah um they all are great i
don't have a winner yep in my mind
supporting actor in a comedy anthony
carrigan barry brett goldstein ted lasso
tohibjimo ted lasso nick mohammed ted
lasso tony shalhoub the marvelous mrs
maisel tyler james williams abbott
elementary the worst character in
marvelous mrs mabel is tony shalhoub
like he is the actual definition of full
of dread like he's so miserable and so
annoying and like literally like not a
good dad um
also when they put this list together
they should say
sydney sweeney cassie and euphoria like
i don't have these actors names you know
i'm sure that there is a list with that
but our post had no time for that okay
uh henry winkler barry and bo and yang
snl
happy for him i know happy for him best
drama show okay
better call saul
i feel like i'm so [ __ ] over that
show even though i never watched it
never watch the first one it's just
freaking bad no oh it's just like that
time is possible i know it's like move
on euphoria yeah ozark
severance i've never watched that but it
sounds good squid game
stranger things succession 22
nominations for succession i heard 24.
oh wow they snuck two more in and yellow
jackets also have heard good things
about that this is a very tough category
who would you give it to um it's hard to
say cause i could only give it to the
ones that are the ones that i've watched
which is not fair i mean because i don't
watch ozark but people say it's the best
show of all time so like also like where
the [ __ ] is yellowstone where the [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] is yellowstone
because that's who she got it 100
cause honestly not succession
why because succession is like
good
for how bad it is you know no like
they have all the makings of a good show
except everyone is dreadful yeah but
like each episode is like slower than
the next it always feels like the rug is
about to be pulled out from under them
yet they're still afloat it's so good
like you know kendall goes off the deep
end and exposes his whole family yet
they're not exposed right right right
there's like no real consequences yeah
maybe that's like a metaphor on the one
percent you know perhaps but like it's
like nothing happens yet every episode
they're like it's so tense and
everything's about to happen yeah except
the last episode of the season was
incredible because those little shits
got what they deserved 100 and tom is
everything yes no that last episode like
see made this show for me because i
couldn't keep watching the likes of
kendall win yeah
best actor in a drama
jason bateman ozark brian cox succession
lee jung-jae squid game bob odenkirk
better call saul adam scott severance
jeremy strong succession
happy for all them all
best actress in the drama jody comer
killing eve laura linney ozark melanie
linsky yellowjackets sandra oh killing
eve reese witherspoon the morning show
zendaya euphoria
sunday okay yellowstone has to be in a
different category because
where's beth dutton where's kevin
costner no it's giving snub
it's giving big fat [ __ ] snub totally
i'm continuing to look maybe it's you
know
a musical
because i don't see it anywhere well it
really was a great year for tv
it really was and there's a lot isn't
like a one show like
i always think of queen's gambit because
that was like the last time well that's
a limited series and by the way that is
um
there's a lot of them white lotus got so
many nominations no but i mean there
isn't like one show that i feel like is
going to sweep every category but you
might feel that way about the limited
series because those are buzzier there's
dopesick the dropout inventing anna pam
and tommy and white lotus no i don't
think any of those swept like anything
you're gonna sweep
and white lotus is coming back for
season two so how is it a limited series
because it's like an all-new cast i
don't know oh actually that kind of does
make sense um but also some other people
were act nominated for a limited series
such as sarah paulson for impeachment
margaret quality made sarah paulson an
impeachment was incredible like you
literally wanted to murder that woman
she was so pathetic
um and margaret whaley was sensational
in maid yeah having her and she's
engaged good time to be margaret quayle
totally so that's
you know the gist of it happy for
everyone
um nice to see people achieving their
dreams and
it's great
i'm ready for my uh daytime emmy for
outstanding performance in the greatest
web show of all time yeah i'm ready for
my webby i think it's time actually that
the emmys like embrace digital
there should actually like not to make
everything about me be a podcast award
yeah it's such a big category yeah there
could be a whole show the potties you
know comedy drama nobody wants a potty
you know like there should just be like
one category in the emmys that isn't it
really should like in the same way that
like the view and it's not fair to
compare
all the just one category for podcasts
because the biggest categories which
would be like news
comedy
like whatever uh what else is on there
and maybe like um
what's like story
you know like yeah like fictional yeah
yeah true crime like there should be
like three or four because the same way
like and it's obviously not at the real
emmys like at the daytime emmys the same
way that like the view can win and
rupaul wins and nicole byer got
nominated for nailed it like the more
abstract versions of television
but i guess like podcast is literally
not television right so there needs to
be the potties but they need to be
distinguished and so that you would want
a potty and that you are a pea god you
know yeah or a pre god that's the
oscar tony if you can get all of those
then you are an icon and not before i
was reading about someone and they were
so close to an egot and we forgot to
mention them and like
i think the only one he's missing is an
oscar is ben platt he's a tony a grammy
and an emmy
is that interesting that is interesting
i don't know how he'll get an oscar
because he's really into music now not
so much acting except for the politician
well he could write a song for a movie
he could be in a movie musical right
he'll do it at some point yeah i think
he'll be when he got coming up
will he be a pre got actually though
definitely uh uh dear evan hansen was
eligible for razzie because it was
terrible so he's actually a reason he
just needs a podcast right and an oscar
yeah no someone like work on the potties
why not you guys love award shows yeah
cause like a lot of why don't you do it
for [ __ ] people actually consume right
and a lot of people because more people
listen to certain podcasts than watch
these tv shows it's true
but also especially in the late night
category woof yeah that's true but also
not to wake the streis brothers but woof
he's like yeah no it's hard to talk
sometimes yeah terrible um and i don't
even remember what i was wanting to say
this is my experience yeah wait hold on
there's something what are we talking
about and then i always lose my training
podcasts
people actually consume
oh because there are a couple podcast
awards that are like put together by
iheartradio but i heart radio produces
their own podcast and it's literally
fraudulent no it's
not merit-based
okay we're ready to move on to some of
our lighter fare for the day it's been a
heavy day so far i know and i feel like
we've been podcasting for heavy girls
two hours i know we are heavy girls
heavy
you got so heavy baby
do you think there's any two people on
the planet who can like
include more different random show tunes
songs commercial jingles into their
everyday vernacular conversations no
and we're holding back because we know
it's not everyone's favorite when we
sing that has to be like some sort of
talent right i totally agree you said
you're not excellent at anything that's
wrong no like
grabbing musical references at the drop
of a hat right
that's why we deserve a potty oh no
our next story pete davidson says he's
definitely a family guy and wants to
have a kid he said quote that's like my
dream so pete davidson is on kevin
hart's heart-to-heart series on peacock
and a new sneak peek has dropped in
which he talks about his desire to
become a father admitting that he's
looking forward to eventually starting a
new quote chapter of his life
quote my favorite thing ever which i
have yet to achieve i want to have a kid
that's like my dream it's like super
corny
and then heart said that's not super
corny that's the best
god damn thing you could do in your life
this is such a precious conversation
precious and davidson said it would be
so fun dress up the little dude that's
kind of what i'm just preparing for now
it's just trying to be as good as a dude
develop and get better so when that
happens it's just easier i mean
apparently this isn't the first time
he's said this but obviously now we're
all looking at it through the context of
kim because we've said many times as
much as we ship so much like the age
difference is a real
thing and kim already having four kids
um
and pete
you know being so young not having kids
of his own maybe it's something he wants
and now we know that's something he
wants like it does make you think and
it's not just something he wants it's
the thing and it seems like everything
that he's doing and working towards is
so that he can be the best dad when the
time comes and this isn't like a
negotiable thing no and it's like not
like oh i could be a dad if i wanted to
or maybe being a stepdad would fulfill
me he's saying i want my own kid
za
and
now you have to look at the lady in his
life and kim wants more kids she said in
april when she was asked when the whole
family was asked who's gonna have as
many kids as chris like that's six kids
and kim has four i think they're gonna
have kids together kim has frozen eggs
because she did use a surrogate for
chicago and some uh and saint i would
she bring it once or twice she was
pregnant twice yeah um
so
if you read if you put it all together
kim and pete will be having a family
and i heard it here first you want to
hear like a crazy take
i do i love that for sure for sure um
but i kind of like wish
pete like already had a kid do you know
what i mean um and like maybe like
i just think he should have a baby with
carly equally now
i can't explain it okay but i just
watched that pete davidson and friends
thing and like she was on it and like
they're obviously really close and they
used to date so they obviously have love
for each other they've had sex before
and i don't know i just feel like that's
who you should have a kid with and then
get back together with him
i wonder if kim would be open to it but
like if kim really wants more kids if
she wants more kids just as badly as he
wants kids
why the hell not they love each other
they're obviously committed to each
other i know just and as much as i love
them and i don't want to be a naysayer
at all like the age difference just does
give me pause that's it but what part of
it because for most people it's like
an age different really becomes a
difference becomes an issue when someone
wants kids and either the other person
doesn't want kids or already has already
has or if you know she's of a certain
age and she doesn't have her eggs frozen
like that could pose an issue in
actually getting pregnant but like
everything is there
no i know i guess it just seems like too
convenient you know
i'm sure they thought about these things
before they all went public and said we
want more kids and i mean we love each
other how long have they been together
now
like eight months let's also talk about
the trailer
sorry i have no clue what time it is
when was knott's berry farm october
because snl was when you were in bvi's
which was october okay so it was a
little later than that so say they
started they got serious in and not
in october november that's tenth month
now we're in the seventh month nine
times they've been together yeah perhaps
the kid is coming next month and let's
also talk about the trailer for season
two of that of the kardashians that
dropped which made me excited that we're
getting a season two so close to the end
of season one um i was a little annoyed
that like we're seeing met gala content
and it's coming out in september so like
we're gonna be watching may
at the end of the year like it's it just
feels slow
um but obviously everyone is quaking
over the one scene where she's like babe
do you want to shower with me real quick
and he like throws the cigarettes on the
ground and walks away from chloe and
like runs into the
the dressing room really cute so cute
i'm really excited for more me too um
i'm just like impatient i want my
kardashians now
i really do want my kardashians no
no i really do i want more i want them
every week i want them never to be off
like i'm sure that would be really hard
for them but it would be good for me
yeah so that's all that matters yeah
especially like you're going to make a
premium show we're going to be addicted
yeah sorry i just can't because that's
how people feel about the toast
oh my god you know because people always
say like i'm so happy the girls are
taking off but like
i'm not okay right right so you're
basically saying we're the digital
kardashians is what you just said no i
think like anyone would have said that
just the way that like we feel about the
kardashians people feel about our show
isn't that so like nice and it is nice
because we just like sit here
and like fart like talk and you got the
show brother sleeping and like their
only audience and they're sleeping how
good could we be it's so offensive and
disrespectful but they're so gorgeous
when they're sleeping oh my gorgeous
sleeping man you'd love to come to work
with mama oh big stretch from my angel
you look so good and delicious i want to
eat you for breakfast bruno's sleeping
on some holiday merch and he told me mom
it's your best work yeah this is
gorgeous merch thank you mommy you said
brew anytime you're welcome you're
welcome fanny brass and stress um so
pete wants kids and that's just not
something i expected honestly yeah but i
think he should have them i think he
should have them with kim
assuming that's what all interested
parties want
and they love each other yeah you know
what makes me think of obviously travis
and courtney from this season um trying
to get pregnant and then i was just
thinking how courtney didn't freeze her
eggs yeah which obviously makes sense
because she got pregnant by accident and
then just like kept getting pregnant um
but i just feel like they're so like
good about that you know like chloe was
freezing her eggs a couple seasons ago
i just figured courtney would have some
on ice yeah but she has three kids and
she didn't need to like yeah and she i
don't think she ever thought she would
be at a place in her 40s where she
wanted to have kids with her husband you
know she never even wanted to get
married wow yeah just goes to show you
man plans god laughs man plans god
laughs
you know what i know what it really goes
to show you you'll never regret freezing
your eggs and that we're all just kids
at heart yeah that's true i'm glad you
brought that up
um are you ready for our fifth and final
story
i really honestly and truly am a little
sports news a little sn s n derek
cheater admits to the 2001 interview
that led to a fallout with his friend
a-rod he said he's quote not a true
friend wait who did this
so what who was derek jeter okay like i
literally think of them as the same
person so you're like a-rod had a
falling out with aon okay here's the
deets derek jeter has a new docu-series
coming out about himself called the
captain in which he talks about like the
end of his friendship with a-rod who was
also a shortstop in the industry for
that at one point they were close a-rod
at the time was playing for the texas
rangers and derek jeter was playing for
the yankees okay now they had a long
time friendship and now he's detailing
how it came to an end in the captain a
new espn docu series about derek jeter's
hall of fame career the former shortstop
says his friendship with a-rod soured
after a-rod was interviewed for an
esquire story in 2001. during the
interview with esquire the interviewer
asked a-rod whether he thinks there was
a rivalry between him and derek jeter
outside of their friendship because
they're both like these amazing stars
and shortstops i guess they played the
same position okay i would have thought
derek jeter was a pitcher but that's
just me we want a picture not a belly
itcher a yeah
honestly i want a picture i want a belly
same i want a belly issue okay what did
he do okay so this is the quote from the
2001 esquire interview that derek jeter
is holding on to him obviously derek
jeter is the kind of man to hold a
grudge yeah but you know what and i
might have said that before uh
before events unravel but now it just
seems like a rod is the [ __ ] worst
well no it does seem like it's funny
when you think of them side by side
because i don't really think of derek
jeter much because he retired like a
hero he got married to the most gorgeous
sports illustrated cover star hannah and
now he like lives a quiet life i think
he made good investments he's very
wealthy he's not being thirsty at all
whereas like a-rod's post-baseball
career has been just like one disgrace
after another yeah
so here's what a rod said in 2001
no there's not a rivalry at all not even
i mean rivalry like ours is such a
brotherhood that there's definitely no
rivalry there and it's weird because
even with my brother we have a little
rivalry but with derek i'm his biggest
fan and i think it's vice versa while
a-rod continued to complement derek
jeter during the interview the
interviewer continued to press him on
the subject and a-rod said he's reserved
quiet jeter's been blessed with great
talent around him so he's never had to
lead he doesn't have to he can just go
and play and have fun and hit second i
mean you know hitting second is totally
different than hitting third or fourth
in a lineup because you go into new york
trying to stop bernie williams and paul
o'neil and everybody you never say don't
let derek beat you that's never your
concern
okay that's like shady and mean yeah but
he's it sounds like he started out
trying to say only nice things and he
was continuing the journalist was being
a pest right but then he ultimately you
know gave him what he wanted gave it and
i don't think he didn't feel that way
you know it's not like the crazy meanest
thing to say and i think but he's never
had to leave and like his docu-series is
called the captain oh right that i think
was like his whole thing he's a leader
and by the way when you think of the
yankees you think of derek jeter
when i think of the yankees i think of
george costanza okay but if you had to
think of a player i mean like actually
think
probably derek jeter you know what it is
i don't think of the yankees
literally like ever
i think of the mets because ben's friend
pete plays on something what do you
think of the mets who do you think of
pete alonso king vip no mvp mike piazza
please
no put some respect when i think of the
mets like pre you know knowing the star
player and like being best friends with
him and his wife um
but before that when i think of the mets
i think of oh when i think of the eggies
i think of tamar judge
of course and her son aaron aaron
yeah
no you think of derek jeter i'm sure if
i asked you that before this like now
what's in your head anyways that's the
quote that upset derek
i hope they um i mean you don't be
friends with everyone forever but like
this isn't like a real reason to like
literally hold a grudge for 21 years
yeah i guess it's been a long time but
what i wanted to say is reading about
derek jeter and just like his
personality especially now reading that
interview from arad reminds me of mariah
carey's book when she dated derek jeter
you know i never finished that book it's
so good but it was written
very dense very dense the author
had a lot every every sentence like
there's no wasted word right and there's
a lot in there so what did she say about
derek jeter just that she like she
really loved him he was such a great guy
he was so sweet and they had a really
great relationship she loved his family
really nothing negative to say just like
wasn't a match yeah but that he kind of
like was this like soft-spoken
guy
yeah and i like love him and his wife
like she's a great follower on instagram
can't recommend it enough love
and i don't know i if you had never said
like said the name derek jeter he
probably wouldn't have popped into my
mind for at least 15 years and so it's
nice to be reminded of a new york hero
and now you could go like when you have
dinner with ben and you could be like oh
my god i hear about that jeter
docuseries crazy about the a-rod team
totally maybe i'll actually watch it ben
would love that yeah oh that's a nice
thing even though like i love espn and
they're you know thirst for cinema but i
have watched like two of their
documentaries and they were two of the
most long and dreadful things like the
o.j simpson one which i could never tire
like the o.j simpson story is one of the
craziest stories in american history the
kardashian involvement there's some
robert shapiro like there's so many
things oh my god i couldn't keep my eyes
open it was so long then i watched the
other one that everyone's talking about
last dance thank you um and by watch i
mean like i gave it 15 minutes and it
was good but i was just like
they're moving so slow no the only one i
watch is the 30 for 30 about nancy
kerrigan and tonya harding that's the
only one you need to watch is a literal
like the most important piece of art
made in the last 20 so if they need to
do all this other crap just to one
subsidiary something like that yeah
that's fine you know what i actually
don't really know a lot about derek
jeter like and now that i'm like
thinking about him like hot whoa
yeah what is derek feel what does derek
want and like his name is derek you know
yeah
he's the first elasti so i never think
about the fact that his first name is
derrick like he's definitely jeter right
they call him jeter and now saying jeter
a lot jesus sounds weird yeah it's like
their peter jeter jeter
with derek we have so many episode title
names for today but that let's talk
about life with derek for a second about
how literally that girl wants to [ __ ]
her stepbrother so bad it was so [ __ ]
inappropriate and weird that's what they
should have called this
docuseries 30 for 30.
european will never be it right because
they're hung up on the captain they'll
never be that girl no but here's what
derek said in life
just in case you're curious let's just
wrap this up because here's what derek
said about about the crew as a friend
i'm loyal i just looked at it as i
wouldn't have done it and then it was
the media the constant hammer to the
nail they just kept hammering it in it
just became noise which frustrated me
just constant noise you can say whatever
you want about me as a player that's
fine but then it goes back to the trust
the loyalty this is how the guy feels
he's not a true friend is how i felt
because i wouldn't do it to a friend
yeah like even if you're being pressed
like the fact that you can get to a
point where you'll say something nasty
about someone who's your loyal friend is
not something you want to be friends
with and i can see derek seeing that and
being like oh this is a friendship i
want to shy away from not holding a
grudge for 20 years and waiting for a
rod to approach when someone shows you
who they are believe it it's like if a
fellow podcaster was being interviewed
about like people and you know someone
was like and how do you feel about
claudia and they're like oh yeah she's
great she's nice and they kept asking
and then they said something like really
nasty and shady like something they
obviously like had to think through like
you would be so completely [ __ ] done
with them wouldn't give them a second
thought and then if it was someone that
i'd spend a lot of time with privately
and like was my friend yeah and then in
20 years if you were asked about like
why you guys fell out just like they
said that and i understood that we're
not friends right like i would never do
that so i just wasn't interested in
pursuing the friendship any further
right which is fine
literally when people show you who they
are believe them right and he wasn't
wrong about a rod at the end of the day
no you know at the end of the day all
right so i've had take we've been
podcasting for so long i know i can't do
dear toasters because i have to pee so
badly no end like we have and i have to
pump like another show tomorrow
and i feel like we had so much to catch
up on today i actually i was going to
say the same thing because you have to
pump because i have to pump and i just
think it's better like so what we should
do an hour and a half today and then 40
minutes tomorrow we gotta spread it out
so we're gonna move to your toasters to
tomorrow i just think it'll be better
for everyone that's our final show of
the week um and then we're back next
week tomorrow is our final show yes
tomorrow and they're back next week
monday tuesday wednesday the schedule is
on our instagram we love you guys thank
you so much for an amazing show and
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
[ __ ] subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
on spotify itunes stitcher public radio
i have radio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find out
the morning chose and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
hope you guys have an amazing day we'll
see you tomorrow bye
you